[Music]
if you love curb enthusiasm and let's be
honest that's a rhetorical thought who
does not then you were gonna love the
book of Leon philosophy philosophy of a
fool written by Leon black himself and
the man who plays Leon black in every
single glorious episode that he is on
and curbed enthusiasm a man who I'm
thrilled to be call a friend and a
friend of this program for years has
been our Superbowl correspondent on
behalf of the Rich Eisen show and I'm
pleased to say will be once again for
Super Bowl 50 two upcoming in Minnesota
if Indy j.b smoove good to see you sir
or Thomson Tom and we already talked
about this now no I believe it should be
called foreplay okay what play will be a
great name for it yes well Tom media
correspondent for Rich Eisen show now
he's still spell it the number four
right or would it be an actual number
I'm he's not wrong yes please spell it
wrong so you spell something wrong it
makes people look at it more you spell
able to pee who pees we could do it we
can walk play it's the Super Bowl could
be spelled in Roman numerals but that
would be IV play
yeah you got a special sort of Pete play
I'm always thinking about that well it's
good to see you both before we get into
some good conversation on curb and your
book and everything else could not help
but notice you were at Game seven of the
World Series you caught that you brought
out the ceremonial first ball as with
manny mota that's right and a member of
the Boys and Girls Club society here in
Los Angeles as a ho introduced to the
crowd is a Hall of Fame member of the
boys on the Hall of Fame member of the
Boys and Girls Club I actually went in
two years ago they had the ceremony in
New Orleans almost among some other alum
we all went in the same time and they
have it every year I think this year's
gonna be in San Diego okay we had in New
Orleans man my favorite city and next
New York City but it's fabulous man we
are we walked that first pitch out my
god Nate without Nate little Nate man
and did a great job he was all nervous
but he held that ball
I said don't drop that damn ball boy lot
of people watching this right now you
hold
ball we got out there man burn the first
pitch out man and ironically last night
I'm just had one about galas last night
I actually ran from doing another
interview and I ran straight over to
host the gala last night at the Beverly
Hilton Hotel and always fail this my
second time doing that and they love it
when I pop in man I give back constantly
and not a fun last night man wait a
moment
drop that ball right on round wait was
that for him man
so did you stick the whole game did you
stick the hookbait to the sticks without
you know you know people people people
folks I love the fans but like you know
I got to go home at some point and you
know I repeat I don't know you had a
same problem you cannot leave the game
with everybody else you know you love
you love your fans with other people you
cannot leave it everybody else cause
this buddy
everybody you know I treat everybody the
same and but I can't keep everybody the
same all night you know the poem you
gotta you gotta go home at some point so
it's not beating the traffic if it's too
much it's too much it's been GB smooth
you beat the people who get stuck in a
bathroom in front of a urinal in front
of somebody if somebody talking to you
the whole time about curb I'm a old man
I'm peeing right now we could talk about
curb and get out make it outside funny
I'm gonna take a photo in front of the
urinal said oh man
don't whatever take a selfie with the
urinal behind you you don't do that
that's what you do we go outside we get
out stop yeah good photo yeah when the
urinals behind you well I mean there's a
certain dawn about your business so
we're doing some people don't have that
bathroom etiquette they don't have that
don't have it the bathroom etiquette
down now are you a Dodger fan
jb are you sadly I am NOT a Dodger fan
but I I am a baseball fan of a Yankee
baby come on man I'm close but you know
what I went out there to support the
Dodgers and in the city that I earned
money and great fans out here so you
know these are Yankee fans you and LD LD
LD we we we share a lot we both Yankee
fans were both suffering jet fans you
know although I I am also a big-time
saint for him since I was a kid okay
but we both talked about the Jets all
the time you know
I'm I'm kind of torn between what's
happening now with the gist dude should
be beer 500 you know I'm almost like I'm
scared what we you know I'm more scared
of what we're not gonna get after the
season as opposed to what we're gonna
get
you know we barely slide into the
playoffs that'll be weird for me because
I really I didn't want to tank but I
wanted us to get some good pigs and play
some of those guys on the bench see what
we have right now we're putting a lot
into this journey man and I feel like
we're not seeing what we have we don't
know where we gotten stopped you know I
mean you know you go to Costco even
though hey man y'all ran out of the
Kirkland underwear by Kirkland and the
Kirkland underwear the size large is
gone
let me jump in Vitoria say I got some
more in the back that's what it feels
like the gesture doing here we don't
know what the hell we got an inventory
right now so just a foul a Josh McCown
is the Kirkland underwear we got the
Kirkland no I want to know what I was
actually about it and you walk to the
back I be right back let me go check you
know sometimes in the back so it's up
but most times it's that the top the guy
gotta look back and see what's up top
with all the hostels the perspective
stops so Bryce petty is the boxer and
Hackenberg is the brief don't have a
thing top because Larry was even used
here a couple weeks ago is just like
this does nothing you know what I mean
the winning just enough does nothing
does nothing for us to cuz you're not
seeing what you currently have at the
quarterback spot and you're not losing
enough to actually go get the top
potential guy don't know what the hell
we got we don't know we got right now I
mean we need we need to see what we have
we need to assess the value what we have
right now yeah we keep going out there
winning games or damn oh damn you barely
lose it yeah it's like we have more than
we think we have but that's that's false
that's a false truth for us because what
what happen is no next year it'll be 0
and 16 come on now tell you that would
be the
that would be the most job this would
happen in a failed to me yes everybody
saw me be like this sometimes good from
football not just here it's one team
dominate every completely dominate every
year yeah right now a little bit you
know you really right now you could not
tell me right now who you think is gonna
go to the big game that's here a kid no
I don't think anybody cares who would
you just before we take our break just
for common purposes interview purposes
which AFC and NFC team would you want to
be there so you could have them in your
JB's questions i'ts Oh some good
questions
oh god who hasn't been in a while okay
since the Patriots are out the pictures
out I'm running out of Tom Brady
questions you know me check likes curb
though right he just came around last
year now the year before he got a little
irritated with me before he mellowed out
this year i soften him up a little
cookie question i got him i got him
going with the p the cookie question you
asked him what type of cookie he likes
he's a tough cookie what really cookie
was umeela wafer is cookie so you've
already used some top-notch material
tell you that i think that i don't think
they're gonna go to [ __ ] anyway Steelers
would you want Tomlin I don't think
gonna make it either I don't think
they're gonna make it I'm just there's
comedy purposes and then there's who I
think Mike keeps I want I want comedy
Pappas it's gonna be some I've been
someone upset somebody well but what
they could be good Raiders Chiefs and II
really think I'll make it even man and
Erie I think I've thought I had to
figure it out the Hardys damn injuries
happen so it kind of ruined that no I
think will be interested I think it
would be interesting to see Casey make
it okay and it will be it will be it
will be really cool of course I would
love my Saints to go again you know the
Jets ain't gonna make it this year that
would be awesome too but that
that won't happen because we still
Saints my faith might might say might
make it your mom but you know what the
Saints don't make it you know what a lot
of friends will Cowboys just for the
questions are long I think we have a
great time with the Cowboys you and
Jerry Jones would be an outstanding
interviewer Thank You Jerry Jones oh you
know my my real first name is Jerry - I
didn't
Sherri's always have a good combo kustom
I met Jerry Sanford we had a good Jerry
conversation the Jerry's kind of sit
together
the Giri who call us up - Jerry's little
quote the cherries so that'd be a fun
fun talking cuz it'll give us something
different about two new teams yeah that
we never met before and we talked about
it JJ smooth and JB so it would be JJ
smooth talk to deck guys man good
questions okay but it also will be fun
to see you know your Saints maybe you
could see that say he's old yeah okay
you know when the Saints for the first
time you know I was the only Saint fan
in the room in my house I had a big
party full party everybody what cult
fans you know I wasn't fully dressing
full New Orleans Mardi Gras outfit had a
little jacket on gotta trumpet bees
around my neck man and made pull boys I
mean had I had a tricked-out man had
girls flashing it was crazy the book of
Leon fool with Leon black man himself JB
Smoove is here when we come back I want
to talk to you a little bit about curb
this book and then we asked Larry David
to be judge and jury on certain social
situations when he was here last time I
want you to I'm gonna ask you the same
questions and see let's see how we how
about how it bounces let's see how you
how you mix it up okay do it that's
coming up 60 seconds with JB Smoove here
in the Rich Eisen ship
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show JB
Smoove is here in studio I don't know if
you're aware of this but when Adrian
Peterson was acquired by the Arizona
Cardinals he didn't have a place to live
right away Larry Fitzgerald has put him
in his guest house tell you something
what does that sound like to you
I've always said that I'll always say
that agent Peterson was early on but did
you know so when I see cuz we're going
there tomorrow because it's the Arizona
Cardinals in the Seahawks with me on the
NFL Network and NBC I'm gonna ask Adrian
Peterson if he if he's lamping noise you
should do this is a great idea now I'm
gonna tell you man
Larry Fitzgerald is one of the best
people in the world who store that I
mean true story yeah what he's a
football player or not man yeah he's a
he's a great guy man we became friends
nice guy once in a while some a text
message great game or whatever he's a
great guy you guys should go over there
you should go over there right through
the same scene you know that that whole
back shot Larry walking over to that
guest house knock on that door have
Adrian Peterson open that damn door and
what you're doing how'd I do say LF I'm
an ad smooth you know oh we should do
that first we do man I will do that I
got a little guess house yeah I bet you
are
yeah do you do you have anybody lamping
in there not right now not currently but
people have where did you come up with
little Anthony where did you come up
with that off the top of your head no
laughing is actually a old phrase from
the late 80s man they say I learned it
from my good friend um
Questlove okay let's love the roots you
told me that the original you know to
Public Enemy had a song called Cole
amping Flavor Flav and what that was is
he would lean against a light post and
in this chill out you know from when I
heard what his cold shoulder laughing
that's called lamping ice over the years
you know it has
progressed it has evolved into and I
some want to say what you're doing man
this lamp and it B is this it's one of
you whatever you wanted to be could we
chillin I mean she'll easily easily have
been people are in north pole somewhere
on Alaska so now saw it lost the
apartment so they pitted their rent that
could have been chillin right you're
gonna get exposure to the elements could
be anything I wanted to be are we
technically lamping right now
this is lamp array yeah we lamp it right
now yeah of course you're working lepers
whatever you want it to be it could be
anything you want it to be as long as
you are relaxed state of mind and you
what's going on now when you were here
last time in studio you gave us the hint
that Larry called you up to see if you
were interested in doing this you know a
man I mean a whole lot of flack from
that man did you really what curb came
out everybody they labeled me the the
blue who spills the beans all the time
the spoiler or is all these words they
used the people who you know a total air
it wasn't gonna happen
number one Larry doesn't do a lot of
press I do a little press so damn much
man
between my stand-up shows don't press
they suck oh the book doing press my
mind Crown Royal campaign doing press
all these different things doing press
for and you I told these guys gonna ask
me about curb there's no it's not later
some gonna slip out oh I want to
elaborate to the point where they're
gonna take what I said they're gonna
find a little tidbits and say you know
what in a roundabout way
JB Smoove said the show is coming back
so now everybody wow that's kinda
embarrassing now when I come around
everybody shuts up like they don't want
to say I know what the hell y'all doing
on the set I see what you're doing Jeff
Garlin okay I see you Susie y'all trying
to be quiet Cheryl I see Funkhouser I
see what's going on you all trying to be
quiet
when I come around now but y'all want me
to know if something won't happen again
yeah I mean well but I don't know Roger
tell me I will tell you this much I did
tell Larry dist oh yes that's my first
met Larry I said this shows like a boss
you know me if you got talent people
want to see your talents so don't retire
too early right but somehow those
talents will erode you gotta decide when
you're gonna end so you got it you're
gonna be smart about when how long is
show gonna go and I also told Larry they
make sure the show
whatever your box set is it's gotta look
good on the shelf when immersed in being
an odd number but a box set with a weird
number
yeah that's a dumb ass number you stop
that well I'm gonna make it look good
it's gotta be concise and it can be
perfect your box sets should be
beautiful sitting on the shelf
people love you see a good-looking box
set of Curb Your Enthusiasm let's hold
on me come on Wendy and a good number
well he when he was here a couple weeks
ago he's like he's thinking about it
what his number is but he's what that
stuff starts he's got to think about
thinking about it I see me I'm I love
seven hello my wife and I got married
77074 7s is my bang okay see so
everything I do was in sevens I know
so here's a book again the book of Leon
philosopher fool by Leon black I asked
Larry David when he was here three
questions about playing judge and jury I
want to see if your answers match
Larry's remember bring it again here is
social situations in your situation
number one destination weddings oh man
people love destination well wrecked now
if you go to a destination wedding JB
Smoove are you required to get a present
for the bride and groom is your presence
your present going to a destination
wedding mmm you gotta get a present no
matter what you do
Riley you bring a present to a
destination wedding
see first of all a destination wedding
allows you to change your mind also know
what happens this weddings people didn't
easy they lose their mind and marbles if
a guy on the back out or lady want to
back down and disappear you can say I
lost my I just lost my memory and I
wandered away onto the beach but to
enact a new Beach and that's what he
found me yet I'm so sorry to saying I'll
work out see the destination wedding
allows you to get away from it all so if
you have one here in the States
it won't work because people say uh
you know you you you ran out on your
husband or your bride-to-be what
happened to you Chris
what's a destination wedding it did I'm
telling you now disappear is on a
destination wedding are you saying come
on
yes are you saying that if you accept to
go to a destination wedding it's on you
tell you something you go to a go to the
Caribbean you asking for it you know who
takes your women I'll tell you take a
lady from you don't still dancers ladies
love these guys little still dancers
they always to be dancing people let me
see those still dancers watch out
but those still dancing dudes will take
your lady I cover it in the book it's in
the book they will take your lady okay
see now that once you go to your room
you wonder what the hell is going on
here the bed is all dis shoveled you
know you see handprints on the ceiling
you know why cuz I do heat all his hands
on the ceiling making love to your lady
see you know he never put his still soft
they always still so on when they make a
love to your lady you be careful with
these destination weddings but those
still dances will take your lady see
that difference
the j.b smoove answered was different
from malaria David that was very
basically said from the book don't don't
even go in the book it says watch out
watch out for those stilt dances in the
Caribbean nei to make a bars bars anyone
[Music]
about long legs here's two more quick
ones well if you go into a fight night
alright you're going to the the McGregor
Mayweather fight you're going to
somebody's house and you bring desserts
okay and you put the desserts out on the
table nobody eats the desserts when you
leave can you take the desserts back of
course you take the deserves better you
don't leave them there if they gonna go
to waste yourself he's not gonna waste
is anybody gonna eat these if nobody's
gonna eat these
well I'm normally do yeah I'm saying
well normally do I take them I don't
take them home what I do is this I hide
them around the house like a Easter egg
hunt alright I'll take the tray I said
skew me one minute now go walk around
the house I'll put one here put one
under the bed I just put them everywhere
put some in the bathroom but in weird
places yeah you only find them when you
cleaning up you know if I open like if
you put your broom you're backing under
the bed they'll come back out with what
the hell is that you know me and then
worse than a cupcake getting wrapped up
in a vacuum cleaner it's the most
amazing thing ever you know how hard is
okay
frosting and cupcake out of a vacuum
cleaner
oh man it's awesome crazy so that just
shows them when I bring some over your
house you eat it or i'mma hide around
your house of an Easter egg hunt that is
and they'll pop up months later some
jobs fantastic week later but next time
I come over to see a game and the last
one for you is what are your thoughts
and people who take their shoes off on a
plane you have a problem guy let me tell
you something first thing I do with my
shoes off right I've been walking around
all day
my socks are clean my shoes been worn I
went to the airport my feet are tired
I've been waiting around to get on this
plane you know you might not be a
priority
maybe you and coach you got to wait
longer to get on you know you always I
slide them boots off these boots come
off hell I put my boots up right now if
you if I feel inclined to it you
understand it you put your shoes off and
you relax now I recommend this more for
people in first class cuz in first class
you should be able to do what the hell
you want to do anything coach keep your
damn shoes on shoes on because I don't
want to sit in your trunk it's a shoe
bag horn and trying to go to the
bathroom that's the worst thing when the
middle dude is trying to put his goofy
ass shoes back on and he got to the
bathroom taste me you suddenly had your
students or you in coach sit there and
shut up hold your pee yeah all right the
book of Leon philosophy of a fool I'm
telling you hey have you read the book
yet oh yes I'm taking it all set Arizona
on my flight to Arizona man spread it
around man when you go to that guest
house yes and you don't see Adrian
Peterson s house yes this is this is
knowledge I'm telling y'all man it's a
fun book man I had a great time right in
a minute
you know coincides with the amazing new
season of Kirby enthusiasm it's perfect
good to see you bud
I love you at oh snap JB smooth on
Twitter
oh snap JB Smoove oh good to see you JB
I'm a little question still man yeah
i'ma call Larry about that good but
we'll be back with more normal for more
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Rich
Eisen show app